Este es un vídeo especial.
No vamos a hablar de política como tal sino
de COMUNICACIÓN política.
Es decir, de cómo vender mensajes políticos
para ganar una campaña electoral.
Y lo vamos a hacer analizando la campaña
electoral de las elecciones españolas.
Como sabéis, ayer mismo hubo elecciones generales
en España.
Y de eso es de lo que vamos a hablar hoy.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos.
Si ya sois seguidores de VisualPolitik, seguro
que estaréis muy sorprendidos ¿Cómo hemos
podido hacer un análisis tan rápido?
Normalmente, en este canal tardamos varias
semanas para preparar un vídeo.
Investigamos hasta el último detalle.
Por eso solemos decir que estamos orgullosos
de llegar tarde.
Si queréis actualidad rabiosa, tenéis otros
medios.
Aquí vamos más allá.
Y de hecho, este vídeo lo hemos grabado días
antes de las elecciones ¿Por qué?
Porque no vamos a centrarnos en los resultados
sino en la campaña electoral.
Como sabéis, antes de ser YouTuber, yo me
dedicaba precisamente a trabajar en elecciones.
Así que hoy vamos a hacer un análisis totalmente
técnico.
Vamos a dejar las ideas políticas a un lado
y nos vamos a centrar en cómo vender mensajes.
Así que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es
¿Qué partidos tenían el mejor eslogan de
campaña?
¿Cómo se diseña un buen cartel electoral?
¿Qué partidos han hecho una peor campaña?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
Da igual desde donde estéis viendo este vídeo,
si os gusta la política, España está viviendo
una edad de oro de las campañas.
Tenemos de todo: un primer ministro que perdió
el gobierno tras una moción de censura en
el parlamento, una crisis constitucional con
una región que quiere separarse del resto
del país y todo esto aliñado con la salsa
picante del estancamiento económico.
Vamos que sólo nos falta un Brexit para completar
el cromo.
En este contexto, es cuando han aparecido
montones de partidos políticos nuevos.
Veréis, hasta el año 2014, las elecciones
españolas se resumían en DOS partidos políticos:
el Partido Popular, de centro derecha y el
Partido Socialista, de centro izquierda.
Por supuesto que también existía un enorme
abanico de partidos locales que tenían, y
tienen, un poder enorme en su región.
También teníamos otros partidos más pequeños
que presentaban candidatos en toda España
pero, seamos honestos, a duras penas conseguían
un par de diputados.
En otras palabras, por aquellos años, este
país se consideraba una democracia BIPARTIDISTA
¿Y eso qué significa desde el punto de vista
de la estrategia política?
Pues que las elecciones eran lo que se conoce
como un JUEGO DE SUMA 0.
Un juego de suma 0 es un tipo de juego donde
lo que pierde uno lo gana el otro.
Es decir, bastaba con que tu contrincante
perdiera popularidad para que, automáticamente,
la ganaras tú.
Por ejemplo, en el año 2011, la derecha ganó
las elecciones sin apenas hacer ningún esfuerzo
¿Por qué?
Porque los votantes estaban muy decepcionados
con el gobierno, que era de izquierdas.
Y como los escaños del parlamento son un
número fijo, 350 diputados, lo que pierde
uno lo gana el otro
En otras palabras… que por aquel entonces,
las elecciones eran más aburridas que un
maratón de las Chicas Gilmore.
¡Pero no solo eso!
Veréis, en España, las elecciones al parlamento
tienen circunscripción provincial ¿Y eso
qué significa?
Pues que un votante de Madrid vota a una lista
de candidatos por la provincia de Madrid.
Y un votante de Barcelona vota a una lista
de candidatos por la provincia de Barcelona.
Cada provincia tiene más o menos escaños
dependiendo de la población.
Por ejemplo, yo soy de Valladolid, que es
una provincia pequeñita.
En mi provincia
hay 5 escaños.
En un sistema bipartidista, esos 5 escaños
siempre se reparten de la misma forma: 3 para
uno y 2 para otro.
En el caso de Valladolid, que siempre ha sido
un bastión de la derecha, el resultado era
tan fascinante como un solo de triángulo.
3 escaños para los populares y 2 para los
socialistas.
Y todo esto explica que, en aquella época,
la campaña electoral era un mero trámite.
Mirad, por ejemplo, un spot electoral del
partido electoral en 2011.
Sin embargo, a partir de 2014, las cosas cambiaron
para siempre con estos dos señores que veis
en pantalla, que se llamaban PABLO IGLESIAS
e ÍÑIGO ERREJÓN.
Estos dos señores eran profesores de Ciencias
Políticas en Madrid y habían trabajado toda
su vida como asesores de campaña en Izquierda
Unida, que era un partido minoritario de extrema
izquierda.
En el año 2014, se marcharon de este partido
y decidieron montar su propio proyecto político.
Una nueva formación electoral a la que llamaron
PODEMOS.
Elecciones europeas 2014
Podemos se convierte en la sorpresa y logra
cinco escaños en Estrasburgo
Desde el punto del vista del marketing político,
Podemos era el Google de la política.
Algo nunca visto que cambió la escena española
para siempre.
De repente, ya no había 2 partidos grandes
sino 3 ¡Pero la historia no termina aquí!
Podemos consiguió arrasar en el hueco que
quedaba a la izquierda del Partido Socialista.
¡Pero la cosa no termina aquí!
Seguimos en el año 2014.
Por aquel entonces, la economía española
no terminaba de mejorar y los medios estaban
copados por la crisis catalana.
Por si todo esto fuera poco, el gobierno conservador
de Mariano Rajoy coleccionaba escándalos
de corrupción.
En otra palabras, que había hueco para un
nuevo partido.
Un partido que estaría en el espacio ideológico
que quedaba entre los socialistas y los populares.
Y ese partido era Ciudadanos.
¡Exacto!
En las elecciones de 2015, los españoles
ya no teníamos 2, ni 3 grandes partidos a
elegir sino 4.
Y aquí es cuando la política española dejó
de ser un juego de suma 0 para convertirse
en lo que conocemos como un JUEGO COOPERATIVO.
En un juego de suma 0, el hecho de que tu
contrincante pierda no significa que tú vayas
a ganar.
En otras palabras, el Partido Popular iba
a perder muchos escaños en el parlamento
¡Pero eso no significa que los fueran a ganar
los socialistas!
Podían ganarlo Ciudadanos o Podemos.
En otras palabras: de repente, los partidos
políticos se jugaban mucho en campaña electoral
¿Recordáis ese anuncio electoral que os
puse antes?
Pues mirad lo que hizo ese mismo partido político
en el año 2016.
Creo que la diferencia salta a la vista.
Dejando a un lado las ideologías, este spot
es una obra maestra: está dirigido a un público
concreto y da una razón clara para que les
voten ¡Pero esperad un momento porque los
juegos cooperativos tienen otra característica
muy interesante!
Como su propio nombre indica, exigen que todos
los jugadores cooperen.
Y eso, en política, se traduce en pactos
electorales.
Con sólo dos partidos grandes, formar gobierno
era pan comido.
Sin embargo, ahora ya no hay ganadores claros
y las coaliciones de gobierno son la norma.
Y eso explica que repetir elecciones se esté
convirtiendo en una tradición tan española
como la paella, la siesta e insultar a Enrique
Bumburi.
Y aquí es cuando llegamos a estas últimas
elecciones: noviembre de 2019.
En este caso ya no tenemos 4, ni 5, sino 6
partidos políticos que se presentan a nivel
nacional y tienen posibilidades de entrar
en el parlamento.
Sí, habéis oído bien, 6 partidos.
Eso significa una competición salvaje.
Por supuesto que, al ser unas elecciones convocadas
casi por sorpresa, los equipos de campaña
no han tenido mucho tiempo para preparar sus
estrategias.
En cualquier caso, ahora vamos a ver muy buenos
ejemplos de buena comunicación política.
Y aquí es donde viene el análisis que estabais
buscando.
Vamos a ver los 6 posters de campaña de los
6 grandes partidos que se presentan.
Y sí, ya lo sé, estamos en 2019: los carteles
de campaña ya no son tan importantes como
lo eran hace 30 años.
Hoy en día, la auténtica batalla está en
la televisión o en Internet.
Pero aún así, los carteles siguen siendo
un buen reflejo de cómo han enfocado las
elecciones cada uno de los partidos.
¿Estáis listos?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LA CAMPAÑA ELECTORAL EN POSTERS
La primera regla en la comunicación política
es “no importa que te quieran, sólo que
te voten”.
Un buen estratega de campaña no busca hacer
cosas bonitas ni originales: busca hacer cosas
que ganen votos entre un nicho de potenciales
votantes.
Es decir, que es muy importante tener en cuenta
el mensaje y el público al que va dirigido.
Por ejemplo, este anuncio…
Tal vez a muchos no os convenza para votar
a Podemos.
En este caso, es muy probable que sea porque
no sois el tipo de público al que va dirigido.
Así que recordad, no se trata de ganar el
cariño del público sino los votos necesarios
para ganar las elecciones.
Ese es el único objetivo.
La segunda regla de la comunicación política
es que todo, absolutamente todos los elementos
que usamos tienen que estar a disposición
del mensaje que queremos transmitir.
Cada palabra en un discurso cumple un objetivo.
Pero no sólo hablamos con palabras.
La imagen es un lenguaje en sí mismo.
Así que el diseño de un poster de campaña
es importante.
Dicho esto, vamos con los carteles.
Los he colocado en orden de mejor a peor.
Y, de nuevo, no estamos hablando de qué partido
tiene las mejores ideas ni a qué partido
he votado.
Hoy vamos a centrarnos en la comunicación
política.
Y por eso, empezamos con el mejor de todos
los posters de campaña: el poster de PODEMOS
y su candidato, Pablo Iglesias.
Este poster es una auténtica obra maestra
de la política.
Como os decía, Podemos es, junto con Más
País, el partido más a la izquierda de España.
Desde que nacieron, se vendieron como el partido
que realmente representa al ciudadano de a
pie, a la gente trabajadora, que, en su narrativa,
está desatendida por los políticos tradicionales.
Y por eso, a diferencia de los carteles tradicionales
donde sólo aparece el candidato con un fondo
neutro, aquí vemos a un montón de gente
detrás del político.
Gente cuidadosamente seleccionada para mostrar
diversidad de género, de raza y de edad ¡Pero
no sólo eso!
Fijaos en dos detalles muy importantes.
El encuadre y el ángulo.
En casi todos los posters de campaña, el
candidato aparece en primer plano.
De tal forma que, cuando lo vemos impreso
en una valla publicitaria, vemos una cara
gigante.
En este caso, sin embargo, Pablo Iglesias
aparece en plano medio, casi general… como
si fuera una persona más.
Y además, la foto está hecha desde arriba.
Normalmente, cuando queremos ensalzar a una
persona, colocamos la cámara desde abajo,
en lo que se llama un contrapicado.
Pero en este caso está arriba, mostrando
que Pablo Iglesias es sólo uno más.
Un hombre del pueblo.
Votarle a él significa votar al pueblo.
Y por eso el eslogan tiene un doble significado.
Fijaos bien: “un gobierno contigo”.
Por un lado, es una referencia más al pueblo
que dice representar y, por el otro, una referencia
al pacto electoral que está dispuesto a hacer.
¿Y con quién quiere pactar Pablo Iglesias?
Exacto, con los Socialistas, que son el gran
partido del centro izquierda.
Y precisamente ESE es el segundo mejor cartel
de esta campaña.
Si el cartel de Pablo Iglesias era un cartel
amable, que muestra a una persona cercana,
el de los Socialistas es todo lo contrario
¿Por qué?
Pues porque Pedro Sánchez no puede presentarse
como un hombre del pueblo ¡Es el presidente
del gobierno!
En su caso, su gran fortaleza es el hecho
de tiene poder.
De que es muy probable que termine siendo
el próximo primer ministro.
De hecho, fue el quien convocó las elecciones
para conseguir gobernar en minoría.
Y precisamente por eso, su eslogan dice “AHORA
SÍ.
PUNTO.”.
Es decir, que sí, que ahora es la buena.
Ahora vamos a gobernar.
Y lo vamos a hacer porque lo digo yo, que
miro a la cámara con esa firmeza y esa seriedad
de ser el presidente del gobierno ¡Pero fijaos
en otro detalle más!
Hay una característica muy típica en todos
los carteles que hacen los socialistas: romper
los encuadres y las palabras.
Es decir, la frase está cortada en trocitos
sin ningún sentido.
Esto es una marca de estilo que viene del
año 2004.
En ese momento es cuando los socialistas ficharon
a un publicista que se llamaba JOAN CAMPMANY.
Este hombre introdujo varias innovaciones
en las fotos de campaña.
Hasta entonces, los candidatos aparecían
así:
A partir de Campmany, los candidatos socialistas
empiezan a aparecer con la frente cortada
por arriba, sólo con la mitad izquierda de
la cara o mostrando detalles muy específicos.
En opinión de Campmany, esto sirve para transmitir
esa imagen de juventud, cambio y progresismo
con la que se quiere identificar el centro
izquierda ¡Pero esperad un momento porque
este poster tiene algo aún más interesante!
Fijaos bien en la imagen ¿No os falta algo?
Fijaos bien… es el poster de un candidato
para unas elecciones.
Un candidato del Partido Socialista… pero…
¿Y dónde está el logo?
¿Se les habrá olvidado?
¡Pues claro que no!
El diseñador ha quitado el logo a propósito
¿Por qué?
Pues muy sencillo… porque no quieren que
votes pensando en un partido político.
El mensaje central de la campaña del PSOE
es que ya es el presidente del gobierno.
Es decir, es el voto útil y el voto a la
estabilidad.
Si quieres un gobierno firme, tienes que votar
a Pedro Sánchez.
Olvídate de las siglas por un momento y vota
por formar un gobierno.
Como veis, un mensaje simple, sencillo y efectivo.
Pero vamos con el siguiente poster.
El Partido Popular, Centro derecha.
Hasta el año 2015, este partido solía trabajar
con agencias de publicidad muy pequeñas.
Pero en los últimos años han empezado a
contratar a firmas mucho mejores.
En las últimas campañas han estado trabajando
con SHACKLETON y ahora están con NOHO.
Para que os hagáis una idea, NOHO es una
de las agencias que más premios se está
llevando en los últimos años.
De hecho, los mismos que hacen los anuncios
de Beefeater o de Jaguar en España hacen
también la publicidad del PP.
Y así tenemos este poster.
Fijáos la diferencia con este otro de hace
sólo 4 años.
Hemos pasado de una luz neutral a una luz
natural, que transmite esperanza.
Fijaos que los brillos blancos resaltan los
ojos y las facciones del candidato.
Es una foto radiante.
Y la expresión del candidato, de Pablo Casado,
es dura pero a la vez amable.
Es un nuevo día.
Es el cambio que representa el PP ¿Y qué
me decís del eslogan?
“Por todo lo que nos une”.
En un momento donde los separatistas catalanes
llenan titulares de prensa, donde parece que
los partidos políticos no se ponen de acuerdo,
el PP se presenta como el partido de la unidad.
Sin duda alguna, este es el mejor poster de
campaña de la historia de los populares.
Quien quiera que lo haya hecho se merece una
buena cesta de navidad.
Por el momento, estos tres posters son de
lo mejorcito que hemos visto nunca en campañas
electorales españolas.
Ahora vamos con la categoría más mediocre.
Y eso nos lleva a hablar de… VOX!
VOX es el partido más a la derecha de todos.
Toda su campaña se basa en el patriotismo:
España, bandera y mano dura contra los separatistas
catalanes.
Y por eso su eslogan incluye la palabra España,
tiene una bandera y muestra al candidato,
a Santiago Abascal como un líder fuerte.
Se puede ver en su mirada altiva en plan…
“Soy Santiago Abascal y… ¡¡¡SOY ESPAÑOL!!!”
Por lo demás, es un cartel bastante clásico.
Luz neutral, candidato mirando de perfil y
fondo con naturaleza.
No es una obra maestra pero hay que reconocer
que cumple su objetivo.
Llega a sus potenciales votantes, y les manda
un mensaje atractivo.
De nuevo, atractivo para ellos.
Si tú has votado a Podemos, este cartel no
te va a gustar.
Pero es que, en ese caso, tu no eres el público
al que se dirigen.
Pero ahora atentos porque vamos con los diseños
realmente malos.
Es decir, los posters que probablemente, lejos
de ayudar a ganar votos, han servido para
restar votos.
Y en esta categoría tenemos que empezar por
MÁS PAÍS.
Para los que no lo conozcáis, más país
es un spin off de Podemos.
Es decir, es otro partido que se coloca a
la izquierda del espectro y que está dirigido
por uno de los mejores estrategas de campaña
que ha tenido España, Íñigo Errejon.
Este diseño es un ejemplo perfecto de lo
que os decía antes: lo importante en unas
elecciones no es que te quieran sino que te
voten.
Desde el punto de vista estético, este cartel
podría ser el poster de una película.
Es original, es llamativo y hasta diría que
es bonito.
Pero ¿Qué sentido tiene el hecho de que
el candidato esté en esos tonos verdes?
¿Por qué lo meten en la forma de una papeleta
entrando en la urna?
Se trata de una imagen en la que la cara del
candidato no destaca y que ni siquiera tiene
un mensaje claro.
Más País es el nombre del partido ¿Es de
izquierdas?
¿Es de derechas?
¿Hacia quién va dirigido?
No se sabe.
Y por eso, aunque sea muy bonito, es un diseño
poco efectivo.
Pero tranquilos porque hay un diseño aún
peor.
Hay un cartel que muestra todo lo que nunca
hay que hacer en política.
Sí, estoy hablando de este cartel.
Como decíamos antes, Ciudadanos es el partido
que queda entre los socialistas y los populares.
Es algo así como el partido de centro.
El primer error de este cartel es el eslogan
¿Os recuerda a algo?
¡Exacto!
Es un plagio del eslogan con el Emmanuel Macron
ganó las elecciones francesas hace 2 años.
Es un plagio tan evidente que cualquiera puede
darse cuenta.
Así que, el mensaje en este caso es “vamos
a imitar a cualquier político que esté de
moda en Europa… hoy es Emmanuel Macron,
mañana saldremos disfrazados de Greta Thumberg
o de Donald Trump si hace falta” ¡Pero
no sólo eso!
Fijaos en la composición ¿Os recuerda a
algo?
¡Exacto!
Es la misma idea que el poster de Podemos…
pero mal hecha.
En este caso también vemos al candidato,
Albert Rivera, rodeado de gente.
Y también están en plena acción: no posan
sino que están caminando ¿El problema?
Que en el poster de Podemos, están en un
entorno natural.
Por supuesto que en la foto de Pablo Iglesias
han cuidado hasta el último detalle.
Pero no es un montaje, o al menos no lo parece.
La foto de Ciudadanos está hecha en un estudio
¡Y se nota!
Mirad el fondo neutro, la luz… Es un quiero
y no puedo.
Por un lado, quieren presentar al candidato
rodeado de seguidores… pero el mensaje que
transmiten es que todo es bastante fake.
De nuevo, no estoy diciendo ni que me guste
Podemos ni que no me guste Ciudadanos.
Pero desde el punto de vista de la campaña,
está claro quién ha hecho un mejor trabajo.
Tanto en el poster como en el resto de la
estrategia.
Pero ahora llega vuestro turno ¿Cuál ha
sido la campaña que más os ha gustado en
estas elecciones?
Y a los que nos veáis desde Latinoamérica…
¿Qué partido hace las mejores campañas
en vuestro país?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, como siempre, recordad que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a VisualPolitik y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto.